un ensemble de douze ong sont venus
interpeller le gouvernement français à
l'occasion du sixième anniversaire du
début de la guerre au yémen
douze ong telles amnesty international
oxfam life idh ou encore médecins du
monde
elles ont organisé un die in c'est à
dire que des militants vêtus de noir se
sont allongés par terre pour symboliser
les morts au yémen
on sait que le pays souffre d'une très
grave crise humanitaire et la france a
été pointée du doigt accusés de
complicité silencieuse pourquoi y'a
parce que la france vend des armes aux
pays de la coalition comme l'arabie
saoudite ou encore les émirats arabes
unis des armes
qualifié à deux défensives la france
entretient le flou or un rapport
militaire de 2018 explique ses armes sur
le terrain peuvent être utilisées de
manière offensive on écoute cyril blain
de l'eye fi dh on est là pour
interpeller les autorités françaises et
l'opinion public français qui doit
absolument savoir le rôle que la france
joue dans ce conflit la france est un
très grand exportateur d'armes le 2 ou
le troisième dans le monde mais elles
vont massivement au parti ou quoi de ce
conflit essentiellement d'ailleurs à
l'arabie saoudite qui est le premier
client de la france en terme d'art et
aux émirats arabes unis
c'est ces états se rendent se rendent
coupables de crimes de guerre au yémen
et la france risque en leur fournissant
des armes en toute connaissance de cause
des risques qu'elle prend de se rendre
complices de ces crimes de guerre il
faut ajouter que ce flou inquiète les
parlementaires français
rapport est paru en novembre 2020 et
demandent davantage de transparence sur
les ventes d'armes car il n'existe qu'un
rapport d'information annuel à ce sujet
les deux députés rapportant ont demandé
la création d'un groupe de travail
commun à l'assemblée nationale et au
sénat pour assurer un meilleur contrôle
sur les ventes d'armement françaises